Welcome back everyone big surprise marvel
just dropped a brand-new Shang Chi trailer video
So we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of Easter eggs.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos the
movie is coming out in September so you won't
have to wait that long for the next really
big marvel movie.
If know everyone is wondering when that Spider-Man
No Way Home trailer is going to drop don't
worry I'll address that at the end of this
video too but they start this trailer with
that funny scene of the tournament of him
actually just entering the ring for the first
time in his friend Katy sitting there wondering
where did your shirt go, what did they do with it
So it sounds like they just rip it off them
when he goes into the tournament.
He shrugs like I don't know I.
What's going on here, this might be before
he winds up fighting the abomination it might
be like the very first fight because way they
pace things out in the last trailer you see
them standing in the crowd watching Wong get
his ass handed to him by the abomination who's
finally back and on but is wondering what
he's been doing this whole time since avengers
infinity war and the events of the incredible
hulk movie yet a picture Julia Louis Dreyfuss
character just standing off of screen just
getting ready to recruit him the minute the
tournament is over like a I have a special
assignment for you for the warning for the
black widow movie to if you've not seen black
widow so in the black widow movie post credit
scene we actually found at the yelena belova
has been working for her for a while after
the events of Avengers endgame, just seems
like she's going around the MCU collecting
a group of antiheroes in a very thunderbolts
or dark avengers type of team it seems that
she's got the raft on speed dial so that she
can talk to Baron Zemo she also just recruited
US agent at the end of falcon and winter soldier
pretty safe bet to say abomination is probably
somewhere on her list.
He says you to be showing up during the she
hulk series.
Next, so we might not see her actually recruit
him either till the end of shang chi the legend
the 10 rings or to the end of the she hulk
series Kevin Feige confirm that Val would
continue to show up in a bunch of different
projects.
This movie just the next big place.
You could possibly show up.
The reason why it seems like you might be
fighting abomination first.
It just because we've only seen the footage
of him actually fighting in the ring when
it's against his sister with the whole idea
with long getting his ass handed to him and
it being kind of a funny moment.
Like wait a minute I thought he was supposed
to be really powerful.
Patty his butt kicked so easily is make the
abomination who looks way more comic book-y now
If you wondering why it seems that he has
the fins on his head yes.
Because that's with the abomination looks
like in the comics, they just told him way
down for the incredible hulk movie.
Maybe because they were afraid of him.
Looking to weird of the time.
Like marvel phase 1 they tended to play things
a little bit safer now that we've gone to
marvel phase 4 we were done a talking tree
in a talking raccoon marvel.
Probably isn't afraid to do really weird things
with characters.
So thus the more comic book accurate looking
version of abomination and they can also play
it as if he just evolve like his appearance
has evolved over time is gamma mutation has
evolved over time, although if you really
want to reach you could also blame it on Loki
and Sylvie what happened during the Loki finale
speaking of incredible hulk you could also
blame the recasting the mark Ruffalo recasting
the hulk on what Loki and Sylvie didn't like
Edward Norton was the hulk until Loki and
Sylvie came along and unleashed all the Kang's
from the multiverse.
There's definitely a lot of those kind of
theories flying around when things get weird
during marvel phase 4.
But early theory.
The whole abomination versus Wong fight is
just to hype up shang chi defeating abomination
to make him seem that was more powerful than
also making his sister seem that much more
powerful when she's able to kick him around
to after he winds up kicking abomination's
ass who has just kicked Wong's ass a series
of successive ass kicking's the other really
big thing in this trailer is you actually
see shang chi wielding what seems like five
of the rings of power.
Now there are 10 rings a powers.
But I think the idea here is that his father
is trying to train him to take over his criminal
empire the 10 rings organization, he wants
to be good in at some point in the movie he
sort of learns to wield the same power that
his father is wielding and learns to command
the power of the 10 rings in a more complete
way than his father does seems more likely
that he's actually taking the 10 rings from
his father a little bit of the time.
Like when he's plummeting down to earth.
He lands you see the energy of these five
rings change from blue to orange so even though
some sort of aerial fight in the rings rectory
shooting after him down to earth and was he
takes control them.
Their energy changes to orange, because in
that last trailer.
When you see them standing often, you see
the energy between them.
As if he's trying to pull the other five rings
from his father, there's blue energy in yellow
energy like he's fighting him using his own
innate power these learn to control it seems
like he's getting ready to take the remainder
of the other five rings from his father was
a lot of confusion about what was going on
here.
Like wait a minute that he just find a bunch
of extra rings.
I don't think that's the case I think they're
still just 10 rings during the movie is a
big thing we've learned since the last big
trailer came out is what's going on with the
great protector Dragon here that he sees underwater
and the special island with the door that
it seems that they're trying to get into Michelle
Yeoh clarify the her character is the guardian
of the secret city, so I'm assuming that she
was talking about the city this behind this
door on this island it has something to do
with the temple that they're fighting over
with these monks in the background both in
the flashbacks like the red monks that he's
fighting this giant war in present day when
show.
She is in his full comic book costume and
getting ready to fight his father like it's
the same group just during a couple different
time periods is still not really clear why
it is that his father wants to take control
of this place or what it is this behind the
store that you want so badly.
The way Kevin Feige explain the Mandarin character
played by Tony Leung whose fantastic actor.
He's the sum amazing martial arts film.
So I can't wait to see some of their fights
during this film is they want to present a
more complex picture of what the Mandarin
was like in the MCU.
Like he was just a typical mustache twirling
villain.
So even though he's the main antagonist of
the movie, he is supposed to have a very good
reason for wanting to get into the city wanting
to control this power it sound like it might
have something to do with what ever happened
to show she's mother like you see her in the
flashbacks training here, it looks at the
same type of training that shang chi is getting
in present day for Michelle Yeoh's character.
Like she's connected to the power of the 10
rings in some way.
Maybe she has something to do with these people
that the monks come from.
Because of all the tiny dragons flying around
during this fight scene in what seems like
present day just based on the costumes and
all the Mandarin's men are wearing I'm assuming
that this is their version of the Mackie villains
from the comics, whether or not they actually
do masculine so they explained that this ancient
culture that created the 10 rings is little
bit different in the MCU in the comics, the
people that created the 10 rings with this
ancient race of space dragons basically who
came from another planet, they just got really
bored they got so advanced that they left
their planet looking for adventure the ship
one of crashing in ancient China in that place
where it one of crashing became known is the
Valley of the dragons and I became the special
place that they were trying to protect this
whole time, so sound like when they're looking
at the island here in the great protector
Dragon protecting this place Michelle Yeoh's
character.
This is their version of that part of the
comic book story will see they wind up changing things
And they don't wind up being space dragons
never really explained that part of the film yet
The other funny thing the you may have noticed
in this trailer.
It seems like it might just be in error based
on the way they cut the trailer and it'll
be fine when the movie gets released, but
during this bus chase scene is their driving
through the streets of San Francisco is that
the big razor fist fight in the other fight
with his father's men you notice the text
on the bus reads one California but is actually
reversed as if they filmed it completed the
special effects and then just reverse the
trailer shut like the lily flip that shot
horizontally so the text reads backwards instead
of the correct way I'm assuming just whoever
cut this trailer for Marvel just did it that way
And when we see the actual movie the fixed
the text and it'll read the correct way.
Sometimes you'll see that with Marvel trailers.
Like though change things on purpose just
to make a little misleading.
Like during avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame all those trailers were just a little
bit different.
You didn't know exactly what was going on
and scenes are he didn't know how many infinity stones
Thanos had at any given moment every once
in a while just some weird thing will just
make it through whatever their QC program
is is a little more footage of his father
in this fight in present day in the white
suit the you see him in earlier in the trailer
fighting this character in green call jangling
is not really clear who she's going to wind
up being of she's connected to the people
behind the 10 rings orbit someone connected
to his wife.
But their fight seems pretty epic, so she
does seem connected to this city that they're
trying to protect here on this island a lot
of people are also asked about Fing fang Foom
and whether or not the great protector Dragon
the giant white Dragon is supposed to be the
movies version of MCU Fing fang Foom because
he's a Makluan just like the other big space
dragons the created the 10 rings.
But the way they explained it so far is that
Fing fang Foom isn't really a character during
the movie, so religiously completely changing
that part of the backstory the 10 rings, but
like I explained my last video.
The interesting thing about the Mandarin's
palace here is that you look at this giant
carving all across his will is super elaborate
it basically depicts what seems like the history
of his family in the history of the 10 rings
like this giant Dragon here represents the
great protector Dragon there's a door here
that represents the door on the island when
you see them wielding their power you see
it light up with the same type of energy that
shang chi is wielding when he's wielding the
10 rings.
Later we 40 talked about how he's basically
supposed to crossover with the avengers and
Avengers five enjoying whatever the next roster's
gonna wind up being.
I don't other than a wind up doing a version
of agents of Atlas or if he'll have some other
team to help put together in his own franchise.
Because I be Sylvie sequels to this movie,
you can tell why is costume is built the way it is
So that when he's wielding the 10 rings this
all that dead space on his arms that they'll fill up
Even though the MCU 10 rings are like giant
bands that he wears around his wrists we'll
see how they explain the power of the 10 rings
during the movie.
This still kind of vague about what's going
on with them because in the comics, the Makluan
10 rings of power rectory just built to power
their spaceship feeling the MCU explainer
will be a little bit more complex than that
you are wondering on a power scale.
They're not really meant to be the next version
of the infinity stones they probably won't
be that powerful just because Marvel had that
big joke during Loki.
Like infinity stones only is this paper weights
here in the TVA was basically marvel playing
a joke on the infinity saga movies and saying
they were kind of moving past the infinity
stones is a big plot devices.
Even though you play see them referenced again
when we just spent 10 years using the infinity
stones is MacGuffin's what I can go right
back to that with the next couple of movies
also probably explain why just any old character
can't just pick up the 10 rings in will their
power is\'85 A special innate power that shang
chi has to wield in order to be able to use
the 10 rings themselves as opposed to the
infinity stones that any person powerful enough
to pick one up could actually use if they
wanted to little explain why someone like
Iron Man or someone like the whole couldn't
just pick up one of the 10 rings and use their power
But if you spotted any brand-new Easter eggs
in this new footage that I didn't talk about
during this video just right them blown the
comments.
I know people still wondering about what's
going on with long why is he fighting in this
tournament, does he need sandwich money what's
going on the actor who plays Wong Benedict
Wong actually said that he made a big deal
about wanting to be in the shang chi movie
when he found out that they were making one
so it sounds like he lobby behind the scenes
to get himself in the movie and they just
found a really clever way to include him.
And as for the Spider-Man no way home trailer.
It does sound like marvel is still planning
on releasing the movie at the end of the year
I don't think that that's change or anything
like that.
Kevin Feige said that their marketing departments
at marvel and Sony both coordinates that they
don't overlap there trailers too much worst
case scenario I think is the way to the shang
chi movie his theaters in those attached the
Spider-Man no way home trailer to that they'll
be whole bunch of videos coming up marvel's
what if series is going to be the next big thing
i'll be doing videos for that will start really
soon in the next couple weeks.
Make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any those one click here
for my brand-new Loki video about how Iron
Man knew about Kang in the MCU and click here
for that brand-new first look at Ben Affleck's
Batman in the flash movie.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!